hello and welcome to my tutorial
concerning the logging ability of python
which is actually built right on in so
you don't have to download anything you
just have to import logging
once you begin building larger programs
incorporating a lot of variables it can
be pretty useful to utilize log the
logging feature
um also if you're maybe like adding to
the program over a long period of time
and you might forget some of the older
stuff that you had done even and all
that and not quite remember how your
program typically goes
uh also if you're working like with a
team it can be really really helpful
like when you're collaborating to use
logging just so someone can figure out
what why something isn't quite driving
with your
function or whatever
um it is possible to do pretty much all
of the same logging stuff uh with just
you know saving and appending to a
notepad file all the stuff that i've
already shown you guys how to do
but what's nice about the logging
feature is it has one built-in
quote-unquote levels or hierarchical or
hierarchies
um
for you know what kind of
log that
string will be
so it kind of saves you a lot of time
down the line
if you want to change the amount of
logging so to speak that you do because
right when you make the program you're
going to
do what's called debugging and you're
going to need to find you know exactly
where everything's going wrong so you're
going to do either a lot of printing out
or a bunch of logging to a file but then
over time once you've you know
worked out a lot of the bugs you're
going to not want to be printing out a
bunch of stuff or logging a bunch of
stuff to a file and so that's where this
logging hierarchy comes in then you can
also kind of customize
what level of logging you really want to
do
logging is also really helpful for
applications that you deploy especially
with things like beta testing so if the
user is having problems they can simply
turn on debugging mode and this will
hopefully log everything that the user
is doing
and will find you exactly where the user
is having a problem instead of having to
use like processing elimination and
guesswork
and you can also like if you have some
sort of like user settings
uh you can have the triggering of a
warning or error or critical error
log
change the logging level that's set
right so normally
by default it logs warning and above uh
which is a good a good thing once you've
finished your debugging that makes sense
um but like say the user
encounters in a
critical warning or something like that
then that can trigger the logging
setting to
drop down to level one debug and it logs
everything again
so anyway it's just really helpful and
it's definitely something you'll want to
have in your arsenal as time goes on so
let's go ahead and get into it
all you have to do is import logging
the next thing
you'll want to do
is specify a file you don't have to save
it to a file you can just print out on
the console
but generally
you're going to want to have a logging
file so you do logging dot basic config
this is you know basic configuration and
here you'll specify the file name
that you want to be the log file it
could be anything you can have a dot
text or dot whatever
but just for the sake of it we're going
to call it logfile.log
and then you specify the level
equals and what this is is that level i
was just referring to this is the level
of logging that you want to do so when
you first make the program it's probably
going to be debug in all caps so this is
going to log everything right and there
are five levels of debugging and the
first one level one is just debug
and this is just a lot of detailed
information
the next level is two this is info
and this is just confirmation uh that
things are going according
uh to plan
the next one is is the third level and
that's warning that's the default it'll
be set to if you don't specify anything
here it's just going to say warning
that's going to be the level
warnings is reserved for something
unexpected
has occurred
number four is error
some function fails and then finally
number five is critical
um
something failed and the application
uh must close because of this critical
failure so those are the levels and you
can say right in here you can use these
debug info warning error critical
obviously written in all caps
to decide what level of stuff you want
to do but for this
we're just going to use debug
um oh we need to close up our
parentheses
so once you do that now let's let's go
ahead and make a main loop we'll just
define main this
we're gonna have a try and we're gonna
also have an accept exception
e all the stuff we've already uh done
before and then we'll call the main loop
here
now let's put some stuff within the
tri-loop let's purposely fail this
tri-loop so
say you've got something like you're
you've you're going to define a variable
we're going to call this math fail
equals 1 divided by zero and you can't
divide by zero so this is obviously
going to break but this is the main part
i mean this is this is it for our main
loop so our whole main loop is going to
fail this means the application's
definitely going to fail
so in this exception down here you're
going to want to do logging.critical
and you'll just want to put in the
string version of e
whatever that exception was
but what you're with this you say
logging so we know we want to log this
information if
it's at the correct level anyway and
this is the level that we're calling it
you could call this level warning but
this is actually a critical error
because the application will not run so
we're saying this is a critical error
please send it in so we'll save this and
this is our logging here obviously there
is no logging file but it will show up
um just a moment whenever we begin our
uh
our little program here so we'll go
ahead and run it
and sure enough we didn't actually see
any error or anything like that but
obviously we got an error so we'll close
this
and we'll come back we'll come over here
uh to our log file
and we're going to open this up
here you have a critical error
root integer division or modulo by zero
so division by zero um so it's it's
logged in this little file for us that
we had a critical error
now
let's say
uh that was deeper or something in the
program so let's say try and since we're
in the main tri-loop let's go ahead and
log
debug
we are in the main tri-loop
that way if you do get an error you know
that well what's the last thing we did
well we entered the main tri-loop
and then we failed so again if we were
to run this
we just ran it it failed oops made it
big
close it
come over to our log file we open that
up now keep in mind it's going to append
so this was the old error um but so this
is the new stuff right here debug
root
we are in the main
uh tri-loop
so we can close that out
we're not going to save and let's go
ahead and delete it and so we can start
a new
[Music]
and then down here what we're going to
do is we're going to say if one is
greater than 2
logging dot info
entered into the
uh
first if statement
uh and then else
logging dot info
entered into the first else statement
right this is just we're just saying
what are we doing we're just making some
info
um this is where we are you would also
just say this is also debug right like
this is probably more likely to be debug
information to be honest so you can say
that and then we can you know do some
things like current hello yeah these are
our awesome little functions going on
so in this sense we can save this we'll
run this one
and nothing really happened but we'll
come over to our log file here
we'll open up the log file
and you know okay we're in the main loop
still same thing as before kind of
divided by zero
now let's do you know one more one more
example and i think you'll probably
pretty much have the uh get the point
um
so let's say we want to continue with
this if statement if one is is less than
two do these things print hello
and then try
um
[Music]
we'll try
url lib
two
dot open or yeah it's url open is the
correct thing url open h-e-p-p colon
google.com
[Music]
dot re we're gonna yeah we're gonna read
that but oops we didn't import
urlib2
so finally accept
now see in here this isn't gonna this
isn't something that's going to break
the entire script
um it could i suppose if you if you
didn't have these trying except here
that would indeed break the entire
script
but uh in this case it's not going to
break the entire script and the only
reason here it did break the entire
script is nothing in our script was able
to run um so we called it a critical
error but in this one i wouldn't really
call this a critical error
it's more like
what is called an error
uh so you would say you know like
logging error because this function
whatever we're attempting to do here has
failed but the rest of the script is
going to continue working and everything
else worked fine but this is kind of
messed up so you would just say logging
error and then i would say
uh
you know it's probably we would just
call it a function probably but we would
say the url of two
um
url visit
failed
failed
um
for the reason of these percent s
we get we'll start getting really fancy
and then we'll say
um
oops not that
this
and then we're going to say percent
uh e
i guess we'll say stringy
this so it's going to log
um
this right i'm going to say url of 2 url
visit failed for the reason of percent s
which just means it's
some sort of string and then this is
saying this string
and then the string version of e so you
know we've done this before with the how
to work with exceptions and just print
out that exception so we're going to pop
back on over here
and let's save this let's run it
let it do its thing it's going to save
to that log file
we're going to close out of this come
over to our log file
open up our log file
and we didn't even get past it because
of the stupid division by zero error
so let's pop back over to our division
by zero
comment that out i was getting in our
way before as well so we printed out our
hello so we know we at least got this
far
you can also use the debugging uh to
print to the console as well
so anyway we're going to close this out
we'll come back over to our log file
open it up
and then we see in our log file that
error
urlip2 url visit failed for the reason
of and then this is the
error that is saved to the exception
right this is kind of like the stuff
that would be printed out in red on your
ide
so you can even save you know variables
that are generated dynamically into your
log file
and with that i'm just going to show you
uh let's say
you're
and you're past the debug so like we
only want a log warning
now so we'll save this let's close out
uh the
uh this we'll just delete this come back
to it in a second we'll minimize that
save it run it
print it out our hello
probably got to url lib2 failed so let's
bring that back up here's our log file
open that up
and sure enough the only thing it
printed out for us it didn't print the
debugging stuff didn't print the info
stuff it only printed out our error
problem and which was of course the url
up to the visit failed because of
this reason here
so anyway
that's basically it to the logging
function there's a few more
intermediate to experience details that
you can use with this logging function
but for the most part uh this is it this
is what you want to use logging for it's
definitely a great little addition to
any big program that you've got and then
also again if you're going to be
deploying out programs to use you
definitely want to have logging
brought into it
and it also saves time
as far as debugging purposes are
concerned you know whenever you want to
debug you can just boom flip this into
debug mode instead of warning mode
and you're set